even when you go into the world of Ted
right like okay
let's talk about TED for a second let's
talk about what Ted did and what Ted is
well there were two things that I
attribute uh the success of tattoo one
was that if you watch the footage of
Wahlberg interacting with Ted before Ted
goes in just the the plate for the baron
he's he's doing half the work for us
he's so in the moment
generally when a CGI character is part
of a live-action film
The Siege the the voiceover is done
either before shooting or after shooting
and as a result there's sort of a
disconnect
so
it doesn't really feel like the actors
are there with yeah it doesn't feel like
there's not a chemistry or Connection in
between and the thing that we did
differently was that Mark and I were
there ever we were on set with each
other every day so I was just off camera
in the mocap suit you know
gesturing as if I was on camera so the
so the technology of the the mocap was
able to record all the yeah the the body
movements and whatnot and so what you
saw on camera was
you know Ted a proxy version of Ted as
if I were on the couch with Mark so that
was the difference we were breathing the
same air we were in the same room it
wasn't the kind of thing where I was in
a sound booth weeks earlier or weeks
later what did you think about how Mark
uh process
your
your like
um energy to work like was was there
like several meetings before you know we
had one meeting and then it was just
like it was just like we've been working
together for years I just I worked with
him so I know I know how he is he's cool
as [ __ ] he really is he's cool as [ __ ]
yeah rounded as [ __ ] it's just he the
thing I I was struck by the work you
know Mark by that point was you know
like
he he was a guy couldn't go anywhere
without being he was the biggest you
know star yeah in the world and it's and
and he showed up every day on set on
time with the on time with the attitude
of somebody who was
there for his first gig wanting to
impress oh he's so low you know it was
like it was really easy
[Music]